each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
come to the today's lecture and
delighted to introduce to you dr. swim
bodo shorts who's a senior lecturer at
university of hot for sure near london
and this is as a photo of the senior
lecturer mins is basically the position
before you can be before the fully full
professorship and dr. schultz received
his bachelor and doctoral degree and and
this this advanced degree that's
equivalent of super PhD from university
of kale habilitation and i asked why he
stayed the same places i couldn't resist
not racing on the sea alright so today
dr. Schultz will talk tell us about sec
Cinco Simon see ya thank you very much
for the introduction and thank you very
much for the opportunity to give a talk
here actually the talk is about work
that we have been doing since about ten
years but it has obtained a new spin to
it by the introduction or the advent of
multicores of many cores so essentially
this talk is a wrap up of the work that
we've been doing so far and trying to
give you an insight or share the
insights that we have gained by doing
that and give you an idea of what we are
currently doing as you can see it's not
a single man effort over the time we
have gathered quite a crowd who has
country contributed very much maybe I
should mention in particular Club
Chairman's Grell because he joined very
Ali and is a one of the key contributors
in this framework
okay let's talk about what is this new
spin all about well most of you are most
likely aware of this there is much talk
going on about getting into the multi
core business today our software runs on
single cars and the multicores are now
entering the mass market you'll get a
dual-core for your desktop and the quad
core is on the horizon and what have you
but if you think about the software then
essentially it becomes increasingly more
difficult to actually make use of this
well dual core is still kind of simple
you know you think of a GUI and you spin
off a few threads and that's fine maybe
quad core as well but what do you do if
you have hundreds of course so then you
could say there are the pessimists
around and say wow you know 50 years of
research and where are we where are our
peril tools this is a dead end we are
never going to solve this problem you
know what is our predominant programming
language is visual basic or it's C or
Java and if you want to have parallelism
then we go MPI you're open and P why is
that so didn't we couldn't be do any
better well my claim my very personal
claim is partly that is due to the fact
how we use the parallel system so far
because we were interested in hpc so
people that actually were using it we're
throwing lots of money because they
demanded the utmost performance so just
think of it if you have a company that
is spending millions of dollars to buy a
machine and millions of dollars to run
the machine then they are prepared to
pay lots of money to programmers that
are really really skillful to get the
last drop of performance out of these
machines and I want to refer to these as
black belt programs because I like this
term I think it's very figuratively now
well why wasn't it adopted in the
mainstream then well if you really
needed more performance than you could
get on your today's desktop then you
just would have to wait a couple of
years and then you would have a machine
that does it so there was no real
going to paralyze algorithms there and
that's I think one of the major reasons
why we still see not a mass market
suitable tool for actually programming
these machines so that is actually
setting up the scene for what we try to
position ourselves in now so what do we
want to address we do not want to
address the back belt programmers that
squeeze the last bit of performance
instead we are looking at the white belt
programmers that the people who are
actually interested in the up lament
application primarily they want to get
the program run they want to understand
the program it should run fast they are
not really interested in our programming
concurrency telling the machine where to
squeeze in a certain thread how to
synchronize things they're not really
interested in whether it is a I don't
know as hell they are using or a cyclops
or is just the GPU they want to write
their program and concentrate on that
what kind of architectures are we
targeting well let's go hand in hand if
you look at this kind of programmer then
we definitely do not want to go for
dedicated HPC machines as you can see
them in the National Labs instead we're
thinking of the machines that are
cheaply available if not now then in the
near future so we are thinking of the
SMP multi-core is like the dual-core you
have right now on your desk we are
thinking about maybe using gpus for this
purpose because they are not really
expensive and then there are a few more
advanced architectures like the cell or
if you look at clear speeds to export or
even the upcoming IBM Cyclops machine
now if we want to dress this setting
than still we want to make use of the
achievements of parallel research into
parallel programming so what do we have
well if we look at the mainstream
languages then my rather radical term
would be we are in deep trouble here
because what do we have well there has
been lots of effort put into getting
automatic parallelization running I
would hope to get some insights and some
success stories to believe in this I
don't the few times I try to do that
were disastrous it never really worked
and if I wanted to get it work then what
I had to do is I had to study carefully
the manual of the compiler and then find
out oh maybe I have to put a pragma here
and oh maybe I have to reformulate it
here and then maybe it works but that is
not suitable for them for the white belt
programmer by no means and if you start
going into this route like manual
paralyzation you have to synchronize
things anybody who has ever written an
MPI program knows how steep learning
curve is and how much misery you have to
go through to get it really right so
Samuraizer said that the the programming
language community I don't want advice
that only has not find the right
abstractions that help us as the average
person to make this parallelism yes we
available well if you for example you
could say I maybe I should have a
liberator and add more if yes if you
look for example Java then you have some
obstruction there but still I'm teaching
courses in Java and exactly doing that
and you wouldn't believe what kind of
errors you can make so it is by no means
easy however myself having a functional
background this is a very important
question here saying can functional
languages live up to their promise can
they really do better and if you ask
people from the community which I'm
including myself in then we would say
yes of course we have charged Rosser and
everything becomes better because all
the concurrency is explicitly there we
don't have to infer it well if you look
at it in practice then yes we do have
the concurrency available but it is very
difficult to tell which concurrency
actually you want to use because it is
very difficult to tell what kind of
granularity are we dealing with so if
you look at the exciting examples that
we have in the past you can see that
essentially people come to the
conclusion well we have to have some
form of annotation we have to find a way
actually to tell the compiler where the
concurrency is worthwhile for
exploitation and so we have evaluation
strategies and more recently the
software transactional memory where you
can actually do this a little bit better
however that requires you to have
insights on your concurrency and that
means the white belt programmer has not
just the focus on his application money
has also to think about how to exploit
the concurrency so
few treats well the example of the
annotations the feature the line we
construct is involved the annotations
that you could have yes what occasions
what you have if he if you do so for
example you can introduce power
construct switch then our may be
exploited by the compiler or you could
if you talk about evaluation strategies
and you could say well this actually
this is a parallel map that should be
exploited so you can attach to the data
structure that you want to do something
as it forms of a higher order function
this is really it's it's really nice
work that has been done there from Simon
Peter Jones and others these high order
functions give you the ability to decide
that there is paralyzed in there yes but
it again it requires you to have this
insight in your program it requires you
to the programmer doesn't know whether
that is that that is true but if you
this is not the evaluation strategies
are to actually make the maps that you
want to exploit explicit so let our
program it is kind of a meta programming
but the nice thing is in a language like
Haskell you can do that in the language
itself so I still think you know
programming should even more be more
easy than that I think we should really
try to liberate the programmer from any
concurrency concern at least on the
surface is there anything well obviously
I claim yes there is something I believe
in the data parallel approach it's not a
universal solution for everything but
for a certain kind of applications very
very well suitable and we have a couple
of the developments there it's ISIL
Nestle signal Simon see as we I will
talk about a little bit more and more
recently the data parallel extensions of
Haskell
slide over to that yeah I'm from a
database community so we I would say we
do this for 15 years already on a
different granularity limb I mean look
at databases they live off parallelism
on data partitioning for a long time
already yeah I I'd love to have a chat
with you because I actually think that
our model would be very suitable to
express certain data mining applications
so what is our basic idea what is our
approach we have chosen to call our
language single assignment see because
we essentially had the idea that we want
to take a language that looks like she
feels like see but still as functional
the reason for that being that we
thought we have to lure people into
trying our language so rather than
asking them to adopt something
completely different they would have a
smoother transition how can you think
about it essentially it is an extension
of a subset of C and if I say sub sub
set all I mean is get rid of pointers
while getting rid of pointers may seem a
lot because it effectively betrays you
of all data structures however all the
other constructs you can leave in the
language syntactically and unaltered
then we have a purely functional subset
which we're dealing with and we decided
actually to not integrate any of the
nice frills you can have with functional
languages like Haskell so we don't have
any variation we don't have type classes
you don't have polymorphism just the
very basic stuff however we integrate a
very powerful generic programming model
for n dimensional arrays so in a way as
a replacement for the pointers we now
have erase very powerful erase and what
we want to do is we want to do compile a
directed exploitation of these
operations on large arrays
now how do we approach the entire task
first of all we say we are not general
purpose we are restricting ourselves to
certain application areas which are
suited to the model of computation in
mind and this is primarily as we thought
when we started scientific computing and
image processing however more lately it
became clear to us that actually it is
much more diverse what you can do with
this kind of approach you can actually
do very well financial modeling that has
been done since ages with APL and
descendants and actually I very strongly
believe in the possibility to do
something in the field of data mining
and that's why I find that particularly
interesting input here another thing
which is in the foreground of our design
as we said we actually do want to have a
very high level of abstraction and we
want to be able to write very
generically applicable functions and
operators and combine these two right
actually programs and that is very
similar to the way you would write an
APL program to some extent however we do
not want to have this bulk in our
language where we have millions of
different operators which have a
predefined meaning we strive for a as
lean as possible design not just for
programmatically reasons but also are
just because we believe that a language
that is to be adapted needs to be
reasonably simple
so why does it have to be functional
surely not for exploiting the the
parallelism that comes out of church
rasa directly but more importantly we
want to have it in order to be able to
radically optimize our programs that we
will see later that this is actually
absolutely key to that and then
obviously our main aur main goal is we
want to compile to a multi-threaded
codes on SMP architectures more on the
question why you decided for arrays and
not for example four sets which would be
even i would say an even higher level
abstraction because it leaves out order
and order very often is not essential
because we believe that the array models
are more powerful and i hope that in the
course of giving you an introduction to
the facilities in our language i can
give you an idea why we come to this
belief the community does sequences or
this streams you are doing matrices and
now based people believe in sense yes
and we are not doing matrices we do in a
race and I'm very happy that you said
this because this gives me a very nice
transition to the next slide so what I
try to advocate here is for the rest of
I don't know four legs 40 minutes or so
please try to come along and think the
race omnipresence of a race everything
is an array well obviously the first
thing that springs into mind and I had
just the proof of that is that if i say
array then people think of vectors and
matrices maybe of tensors but what's all
the fuss about right well if you look
behind the scenes or if you look into
the APL community then you get other
ideas first the first idea that you get
is which may sound strange is while
scalars are just a race it's just a
special form of race but if they fit
very nice in to the pic
then you also can think about it very as
I would say whole meal approach to
programming on a race so what I want to
do is I want to actually have operations
that take arrays and compute new arrays
I don't I don't have this this view of a
large chunk of memory which I can
address where I have inherently an order
but I have the idea that there is a
structured object here and then I map it
to another structured object there and
even iteration spaces can be erased so
in fact you can actually replace
recursion by operations on arrays which
is a little bit strange in the beginning
but once you get used to this kind of
thinking in my view at least is very
nice just to give you a few examples up
here we have factorial no recursion
visible here it's all hidden in this
operation iota what does i old i do iona
takes an argument and creates an array
vector in this time of the length n and
contains all valid indices in it which
is in our model since we are sea-based 0
to n minus 1 then i add one to this
array adding a scalar to an entire array
is defined as element-wise addition so
the result of this is actually the
vector 1 2 3 4 etc to n what is the
product well the product is essentially
a fooled with x so our recursion is gone
or has been hittin in actually this
generator of the indexing space
let's think about l2 norm so what is the
l2 norm well essentially if I think
about it having a vector here vector a
then I have the element wise squares I
sum those up into a single value then i
take the square root of it done very
nice definitely no errors in indexing
here because we don't have any but you
can actually propel this style of
thinking or programming into much more
complex things like here we have a
convolution step something that is used
over and over again and hung it in
numerical codes when it comes to solving
pdes what do you have to do you have to
build weighted sums of neighbor elements
weighted sums of neighboring elements so
instead of thinking it element wise you
can also start thinking very wise so
instead of actually picking the right
neighbor element I can take the entire
array and shift it to the left likewise
here I shift the entire array to the
right then i multiply this shifted ray
with the weight that I'm interested in
and eventually I sum up the entire thing
a very nice specification and definitely
no errors in the indexing
another example we test the convergence
of two arrays a and B so what do we want
to do we really want to actually see
whether it's any position of this array
the absolute difference is smaller than
a given epsilon well here we are this is
an array another array we build the
difference it's an array of differences
we take the absolute value of that that
is the absolute values of the individual
elements then we compare it against the
scalar value apps alone that is we now
obtain an array of bullion's and then we
have this all operator which is nothing
but an end reduce that is we all
combined fold them with an end operation
and again no explicit indexing so how is
the mechanics of this thing let's look
at the l2 norm again let's look at
applying the l2 norm to a vector 1 2 3 4
now what is happening actually the l2
norm is expanded to its definition we
have the square root of the sum of the
squares and then we successfully apply
the individual operations we start with
a square that means we now obtain the
vector of squares then we build the sum
that is we sum up all these elements and
eventually we take the square root
the property that Ares give you all that
elements you actually could have done it
with sets yes and what if you want to
look at our arrays as sets you can do so
now no but nothing is stopping you from
doing that something you're always
painting yourself and therefore limiting
your possibilities in order to do
parallelization that's what I mean of
stance on computation something order is
important Haley so I I would be
interested in seeing why I'm also a
restricting myself and where and I would
I would like at least pose it a little
bit later because I think that some of
the slides that you will see will give
you an idea that we are trying to get
rid of these constraints now why is this
a an interesting example it is an
interesting example because so far I
haven't told you anything that this
really needs to be a vector so what is
preventing me from actually throwing a
matrix at this well then the obvious
question is what what is that supposed
to me well and that is very nice because
you can actually say an N dimensional
array can be considered an N minus 1
dimensional array of vectors right and
provided oops that was an interesting
anyways provided that the underlying
operators are defined properly then this
actually works so let's look at this we
are now flowing a matrix at this L 2
norm whoa so we have the unfolding of
the definition of l2 norm now we have
the square square is defined
element-wise again we're not making use
of the structure I agree on that one so
we have now hear this matrix 14 960 now
we come to the some operator and the
some operator is defined in such a way
that it always operates on the innermost
axis and here we are now making use of
the structure so essentially what is
happening is we're building the sum of
these the the vectors of rows
that is we now obtain a vector here 525
and then we again take the square root
and we're done why is this important
feature well it means that the code that
i have written having vectors in mind
can now be all of a sudden implicitly
applied to huge arrays of vectors and
that is what we refer to as shade
generic programming that is a property
which makes code very reusable provide
it because I see your disagreement here
partially at least provided that these
individual operators are built in the
way you want them to be sure holy moly
well what is generic programming about
it is about polymorphism in a certain
way so what do we need in order to do
this first of all we need to have rank
and erase we want to have support for
arrays where possibly we do not even
know the rank of the arrays statically
then we want to have something else we
want to have something like generalized
selection so we want to be able actually
to select entire sub arrays from a given
array we definitely need to have
functions that take entire arrays at
return entire arrays and then we want to
have all kinds of these nice
Combinator's and even better would it be
if we could define these by ourselves so
then we can adjust it to the needs of
our applications well did I say lean
design at a certain stage this doesn't
really sound like a lean design does it
well the good news is it in fact is
because the crucial conclusion or the
crucial idea that we have gained is we
can express all this or most of this by
one single language construct and that
is the power of this approach as far as
as I see it
so let's go through the individual
requirements first of all
multi-dimensional arrays how do we do
this essentially if you have a three
dimensional array like here we have just
one set of data in a linearized form
here and we have a shape that we
associate to it in this case we say we
have two elements in the first access to
the second and three in the third axis
and therefore we can from the shape
actually deduce of the rank that is the
number of elements in the shape matches
the rank of the array now if we look at
smaller dimensionalities we can write
something like this then it's just
vector a vector means we have just a
shape with one element that is the
number of elements in the vector and the
data is just the data vector how can we
complete this well in fact we can say a
scalar is zero dimensional array the
shape is empty and the data vector just
contains the value so it's a very nice
closure of this representation excuse me
then I've said we need to have
generalized selections and what I mean
with that is well usually if you think
about selections then you often just
want to select a single element however
if you do that in a conditional a
conventional approach then you have
scalar selectors so actually your
selection requires as many operands here
or in DC's as you have rank in your ray
however if the rank is not static then
you can't do this therefore we actually
use vectors for in DC and what is
particularly nice here is that these are
arrays again because remember everything
is an array that means we can actually
compute these indices with our array
primitives we can apply them in that
context as well
now if we if the length of this vector
this indexing vector actually matches
the rank of the array then in fact it is
the scalar selection the same way as we
would expect it to be but if we shrink
the length of it then we say oh
essentially that would be Fortran wise
it would be something or 429 divides it
would be 0 colon 1 colon dot if I recall
correctly or thought a caller may be the
other way around so what it says it we
take all the elements in the missing
innermost axis and here we have so it is
here in the first in the front plane it
is the second row and it's all elements
at the second row if that can be closed
again very nicely so you say if we just
have one index here then we select the
entire first plane that means we
actually obtain a two-dimensional array
or matrix 2 by 3 or if we select with an
empty selection vector than we obtain
the entire thing so now we have n
dimensional arrays now we want to write
these operations we want to define our
combinators and that means we have to be
able to actually pass an array of
arbitrary shape in here and to do that
we have to introduce some notion of type
here because we want to adopt the idea
to actually declare function types what
we do is we actually append the base
type the element type that we expect
with shape information however if you
say this is shape invariant that is we
can apply to any array of any rank then
we just use a star it's kind of you can
think of it as a regular expression
essentially now what does this do
essentially here you have the definition
in AC like notation right
so if we now define our functions in
terms of communities where do the
communities come from and remember i
said earlier i don't want to hardwire
these into the language so let's look at
this particular example and let's think
about the case when these are actually
no we can't do this okay so we start out
defining square however we first define
it on scalar values only so there you
have the standard see definition that
you would expect now how can we get this
to be applicable to arrays of arbitrary
shot shape and size and that's where our
magic construct so to speak kicks in we
called it the wit loop so what it does
essentially is it defines a mapping from
index vectors to values and then we
after these brackets are closed here we
say what are we going to do with all
these values essentially here we say we
are generating an array of a certain
shape and by giving the shape we
actually restrict the index domain so
let's have a closer look at just the
width look here here is the index domain
as we would have provided that a is it
it's a matrix in fact we see we have in
DC starting 0 0 0 1 etc down here and
the in the row wise the first index
increases the mapping I v2 square of a
of IV means then simply that the first
element needs to be computed s square of
a of 00 etc notice a few things here a
the index can actually be used here
which gives us the power to define
things like convolution and second by
construction since we know that these
functions are side-effect free we know
that all these computations can be done
independently so in fact we're having
kind of micro frets here
as many micro sets as we have elements
to compute right and the generate just
tells us what to do how to compose the
entire stuff we also address elements
like a IV was one short in case the
point is instructive at the analysis the
point is you do not have a handle on the
result you don't have a name of the
results that's why I on purpose just
look at the expression here operational
difference because here you
destructively update probably original
ah now you're talking implementation I'm
not talking implementation yet
essentially what i'm saying is you're
computing a new array from an existing
one and in some cases like in this one
if you have a smart compiler you can do
that in place but not necessarily but
what is important to notice is i can't
really access other elements here these
are design independent there is no way
to create a dependency here if you need
this and want this then they can't use
this construct I couldn't really get the
semantics of the idea what what is the
semantics what is it I'm in a way
introducing if you want to project it to
a conventional loop then you say this is
the loop variable so this is introducing
a variable here which stands for in
index yes and it's excessively stands
for different in knots and I'm just you
know it defining an abstract mapping
from my index domain to the value domain
okay now what can we do with this we
have seen that we can extend actually
square to do it element wise on all the
elements but we can actually define our
generalized selections by it well that's
simple what do we have to do let's
assume we want to select with the
integer vector into in double array a
here now what is the shape of the result
well the shape of the result is actually
the shape of a are but dropping away the
beginning extends by as many elements as
we have in DC's here that is if we have
a 3 3 dimensional array here and we have
three indices in this vector then we
drop simply the entire shape and that
means this becomes empty and an empty
shape means we obtain a scalar remember
we have closed it up and therefore this
now doesn't hit us if we just have two
indices then we are losing the first two
dimensions that means if you think of
the example a we had we just have the
three elements of the innermost vector
now this is defining the shape of the
result very nicely now how do we get now
for a given for a given index here the
value again that is simple we take the
index of the outermost dimensions that
have been provided here and we
concatenate plus plus is a concatenation
construct here we concatenate the
innermost in next to it and get the
elements we're interested in done
the simplest example why does job take
two shapes and okay dropping and again
is a shape generic operation which takes
a vector telling us how many elements to
drop in which dimension however in this
case we're talking a vector here and the
vector there so do we have a no we don't
have it pen so essentially what we're
doing here if let's think about this
situation when we have two indices in
this vector then the shape of this is
just the vector containing two so we
have a drop two from the shape of a and
let's assume the shape of a is two to
three then that means we dropping two
elements in the outermost dimension that
is just one dimension we drop the two
and the two which leaves us the vector
with the three
the generators one as telling you what
you type generate out of it the
generator tells us we have a mapping
here and essentially the generator tells
us what to do with this mapping and it
tells us create an array who's in next
space is defined here we have also
different other variants and I will
expose you to one of these here let's
look at the some definition because I
think that some definition actually is a
very nice example for the power of of
the abstraction that we have here let's
define the summation for a vector and
see here we have a slightly different
type and that just tells our system this
is for vectors and vectors only so what
do we do here we actually again have an
index space we are indexing iterating
over all the elements of a we just take
these elements and we want to fold them
with a plus operation and therefore we
have now the second variant wit loop
which simply takes all the elements it
has computed there and folds them into a
single value in here we have to specify
the neutral element of that that was
piece of cake now how do we do the
summation on the innermost axis if we
have an N dimensional array you do it
like this
what is the shape of the array that we
have well essentially we just want to
apply the summation on the innermost
axis that means we actually have to cut
off the last the last acts the last
element of the shape of a that is what
we're doing here drop mine is one shape
of a and what do we want to do you how
do we compute the individual elements
while we simply for all indices in this
array we come compute here we have a
partial selection into a now take that
back to apply the sum and that's it and
since this is going to be a vector /
design we will have this function being
applied here now why is this so
interesting well let's think of what
I've tried to tell you here how many
data parallel operations do we have well
this is a selection here but it's not a
scalar selection it is a vector
selection so in fact this is a data
parlor construct summation we just
figured out this summation is going to
be that summation so this is a data
pearl construct as well now how about
this drop drop is defined by with loops
as well so this is a data parallel
operation as well so all of a sudden we
are being flooded by data parallel
operations they are everywhere they just
trapped in you know like like I don't
know mice or something like that and
they're ubiquitous in our program
without us really noticing because who
would think of a data parallel operation
if you do a selection nobody well not
many maybe
I hope more in the future maybe
something else I should have mentioned
earlier as you can see we have twice a
definition for this for the same
function name and what we do is we allow
for ad hoc function overloading all that
we require is a certain consistency with
respect to the argument types and here
you can see this is defined for
arbitrarily the ranked arrays whereas
this is defined for vectors and then the
semantics of our language is that you
always take pic the closest match and so
far the subtyping hierarchy that we're
dealing with is a tree so that is no
problem in this particular case now at
the latest in this situation those
people that have been into implementing
compilers should start becoming nervous
because in a way it is too much
parallelism how are we going to ever get
efficient code out of this so what is
our real problem we have a program and
we have lots of DT tiny little with
loops hanging around here which are all
nice and data power but how to get them
on the heart of architecture well first
of all we have to try to a grade them
and that is actually something which we
can do very very efficiently and we have
very very worked very hard to get this
done so what we try to do is actually
try to get pull a few of these together
and build bigger with lips fewer bigger
with loops there's not enough time here
to actually go through all the stuff
that we're having just to give you a few
pointers three major optimization
techniques that we have developed all of
these depend highly on the capability to
move around code which is facilitated by
the functional paradigm so if you want
to do this effectively then I do not
believe that you can do it without being
functional or at least being sure that
you don't have side effects
now if the world would be nice then we
would have had to implement just those
however reality is a little bit
different a reality means in fact in
order to enable these we need a total
compiler infrastructure and that is
something we did not anticipate in its
in its total cruelty so it is not just
that we need to have all the gory well
known optimizations like loop unrolling
common sub-expression elimination
constant folding what have you all this
needed to be in place in order to
facilitate those but we also need to
actually specialize our programs from a
cheap generic version to actually shape
specific versions and to do that we have
a type inference system that
aggressively does partial regulation so
all this needs to be in place to make
this happen and that is required to
aggregate all with lips once we have
done that unfortunately our with loop
construct becomes more complicated while
an individual with loop usually is
rather homogeneous we have one operation
that is being applied to all the
elements at the index space as soon as
you start folding these you get a
situation like this different colors
mean different operations here so you
can have an arbitrarily complex
patchwork even worth verse then what you
want to have is periodic periodic sets
where you want to do something so you
can have these periodic patterns and
then again due to folding you can have a
mixture of both so you end up with
really really weird structures that
you're dealing with however we couldn't
care less in a way because we have the
freedom to evaluate these independently
these are still guaranteed to be
actually micro threats now let's look at
how we actually get these micro friends
to a real architecture now so
essentially what we have to do is we
have to map these micro threats to real
threats and as long as we don't have
these architectures of your thousands of
processes then definitely we don't want
to map each micro threat
22 individual threats so we have to
group them and there we actually have
the Liberty to do it in any way we like
it and the way we do that is we try to
keep data locality in mind so we
actually say oh if we're dealing with
these values up here then maybe we
should actually assign them the one
processor because we have you know
whenever we load a cache line we already
get the data that we want to process
next etc etc so the rudimentary approach
that we have taken is we actually cut it
in two end pieces along the outermost
axis all right so here we have read 1
and thread to we did this static static
scheduling and work well however then we
thought well maybe sometimes you know in
particular these are different
operations you will have load imbalances
how it can be deal with that and the
surprising result is that is farther
easy in fact it inflicts almost no over
had to have dynamic schemes and one of
the schemes we were particularly
interested in is a scheme where we say
ok we have actually dedicated this to
Fred number one this is dedicated to
threat number two and then we have some
regions which are more loosely
affiliated to these threats and just in
case someone has done his and his
affiliated stuff then he can steal so to
speak parts from the other however we
found in practice the static scheduling
did it for most applications we were
dealing with now how is our execution
model actually it's very very simple
it's just data parallelism so we have is
a single threaded execution here then we
have a fork which essentially is
entering a with loop we do the with loop
which is totally independent and then we
have to synchronize again at a joint
point and that happens one after the
other now the first thing we observe is
actually really joining the threads is
not a good idea in particular if you use
P threads then this is too expensive so
what we did is we said I know
implementation we do it slightly
differently we let these
threads actually live the only thing we
do is they just wait for a signal to
actually go on and process the next
section of data and then more recently
we actually have refined that we try to
get rid of the synchronization barriers
here and there whenever possible by
simply replicating the sequential parts
of code following the SpMT model
essentially now is that all know crucial
to performance is thinking about memory
here and that actually relates to the
question that you were posing earlier
saying you know what about reusing
memory what about actually trying to do
things in place in order to be able to
do that we need to know that this is
actually the last copy we are dealing
with nobody else needs to see the old
value and that is only possible by using
reference counting as it's well known
from size land there's lots of good work
being done there in that context by can
and others so we adopted that model that
allows us to immediately reclaim memory
to do actually update and place things
and that gives us the opportunity that
we actually allow the programmer to
write really ugly things like you know a
at position IJ v equal 6 which looks
very imperative and very much in place
and it's done actually in place whenever
possible and then we were turning on our
multi-threaded back end and with some
operation some application that wind
excellent and other applications just
let me say it frankly sucked they were
that slow and we were looking into it
and then we found well what is actually
happening if I look back at this here
what is happening if all these threats
for some reason in their local part
decide to allocate memory what happens
if they decide to create an intermediate
array here whew they all want to
allocate memory and roughly the same
time how does the memory manager collect
deal with that well it says up wait a
minute I'm locking the memory now for
threaten on my ex so actually the
locking mechanism here killed the entire
performance however if you look closely
at the definition of the with loops and
how it works it we can actually
statically ensure we do know that all
local variables that we allocate here
are just visible within that threat and
no else because they cannot leave the
with loop anything that is defined
within the wit Lou cannot leave it just
the end result gets out of it so that
means we can actually do a very nice
trick we can actually have our own
memory allocator which has now private
heaps within the global heat that is
accessible for everybody for the
individual threats and whenever a thread
individually wants to allocate something
he does it in his own heap without any
locking so then we come to the part that
everybody is always asking us how will
how about the performance what do you
really get out of it i'm going to show
you two benchmarks here nes benchmark ft
which is an fft or three dimension F of
T here and maybe I should have put in a
slide where I show the code because this
is like 30 lines of sec code really
beautiful recursive distribution we cut
out the Rays and we manipulate arrays
very close to the mathematical
specification and anybody of you who has
seen the NES original at Fort on 77 code
knows that that is a huge difference now
what is our performance we compare
essentially here here we have the number
of processes and here we have normalized
our run times to the second run time so
we have almost linear speed ups well
factor of six maybe not be considered
almost linear but I think it is pretty
good given that you really that we
really recursively decompose the vectors
into smaller vectors now showing these
figures is really boring because what
does it tell us to get linear speed-up
if my sequential runtime is very slow
that i can always produce linear speed
ups so how do we compare against fortran
this is now the SEC runtime / the
sequential is the sequential fortran
runtime divided by the second
time that means here essentially that
the fourth of the sequential Fortran
program was about a factor three to four
faster than us however as soon as we had
four processors we outperformed the
Fortran 77 version and we tried alter
parallelizing Fortran 77 compilers they
gloriously failed so in a way I think
this is pretty encouraging in particular
if you compare the source codes in
particular if you take in a into account
that our source code is like 30 or 40
lines of code rather than 400 or 500 the
better example is any s benchmark mg
again sack against itself for more
processes here we have a even better
scaling and if you compare it to the
sequential Fortran runtime to our
surprise we can see that we are actually
very close so our sequential runtime
actually is very close to the Fortran 77
runtime
now what is the state of the art
essentially my sales pitch is you know
all you need as a C compiler that
supports c99 you need to have POSIX
threads on your architecture and you
have to have cache coherence equivalent
so we can't really get shipped data from
a introduced by the compiler I know I
shouldn't say this it's always dangerous
to announce something in the future we
are since quite a while trying to get
sec 1.0 out of the door but as we an
academic institution that is kind of a
prolong get it difficult undertaking
however we have a pre-alpha version
which we have just uploaded a couple of
days ago in our home page so I'd be
happy to to assist you if you want to
give it a try and we actually have a
mailing list where you can stay informed
how much time do I have left
I should finish okay so what are we
currently doing we actually have the
compiler in place from sacto micro so
the microfiber with loops we have all
the optimizations essentially done we
can right now map it on operating
systems threats on POSIX threads or that
is in place what we are currently trying
to do or thinking of pursue pursuing as
first of all we want to compile these
microphones with loops into a micro
farad hardware that is being built at
the University of Amsterdam and we also
intend to actually compile this code
into more modern processes like the cell
or GPUs or the Cyclops 64 so that is
something that we want to desperately
look into another strand of work that we
have started about a year ago is we have
actually for some application found that
maybe the paradigm of data parallelism
isn't good enough maybe we want to have
an alternative means to express
concurrency and that should be streaming
essentially so we have developed an
asynchronous stream processing framework
that is however more or less orthogonal
to sac so the idea is we have individual
stream processing boxes which are
essentially SEC programs and then we can
combine these two streaming networks
however the exchange of the box language
so to speak is possible so we have tried
to orthogonal eyes these two espurr as
far as possible all this is part of it
of a European project the ephah project
on adaptive systems and the development
on s net is one of the major software
components within that project
to conclude
what I'm trying to say is adopting the
model of generic array programming is
very helpful because it gives us data
parallel programming implicitly so the
programmer does not have to be aware of
that and I think this is what a white
belt programmer would may like however
to compile that into efficient code is
not as trivial as it may seem in
particular if you want to have this high
level of abstraction where you have very
tiny little data parallel constructs all
over the place and you want to aggregate
these so you have to have strong
mechanisms to aggregate these you have
to identify methods to actually schedule
these which sometimes is more difficult
than it may seem and last not least you
have to actually be careful how you do
your memory management one of the key
things that we have observed while doing
all this work is that actually the
function of satin is absolutely
indispensable if you want to do this
kind of optimization we would not want
to be without the functional setting so
the message that I would like to get
across is start thinking erase and maybe
then you may also like to start thinking
such any further information can be
found there thank you very much
you look at another white wire radar
year in the bog rely on time whatever
but I only realized for example when you
cut up the threads and you say you will
have this data partitioning very often
it is important that I mean these
partitions are not completely
independent of each other because at the
borders you sometimes have directions no
well shifted right believe that you I
mean the elements on the computation is
not always independent and yes /
construction you cannot do that example
if you have if you have similarity
computation in like in bioinformatics we
have these matrices where you more or
less generate the result from the upper
left a bar left corner to the lower
right corner that is not the data
operation that well then you are then
you are restricting yourself to a class
of problems that might be listed by
important but probably less interesting
for the future because the more complex
ones I'm not sure I'd love to have such
an application and have a look music
molarity surgeon bioinformatics look at
the what other I always forget the names
the famous similarity algorithms and by
own families if you have if you do have
a dinner dependency within within your
algorithm which is inherent then yes you
can't define it as a data part of
operation the question is and if because
things spread out more or less in two
different screen streams in if we have a
two dimensions one in the in the
direction of horizontally and one
vertically but if you have this then you
have to what I'm saying is the beauty
and the beast in itself is this with the
construct the beauty because it is I
have a guarantee that there is an
independence the beast because if you if
you don't have this independence in your
you have to rewrite Doggett example you
you have to fold operator where you're
summing up things now it's not
independent I mean the director more or
less you have to add things according to
the metal where are we fold okay this
computation is it yet the
synchronization is just not a barrier
synchronization but i can use even with
a bold i believe you can explore
parallelism there because the plus is
cumulative yes that's that's actually
very nice pass that you're playing over
here because essentially what we have
done and what other people do not
strictly not like about this design is
we say the full operation here needs to
be commutative and associative and what
what we do is we do a logarithmic fold
here right so we do this so fold is
therefore but it is dependent I mean you
don't look at each element independently
you always have to always group things
together and yeah this happens i should
actually appear but this happens so to
speak in this barrier the computation of
the individual elements is totally
independent but only when it comes to
the synchronization this is now the full
operation has to be part of the
synchronization here anyway the American
accuracy that now I'm talking about
because I think if you look at this if I
look at especially and I think you are
sometimes have to be careful how you
manage the shape of your boxes in which
you aggregate things because it it might
be dependent whether or not you interact
with many elements on your boundaries
are not a variance in the array so it
doesn't overwrite value he's biting it
in a new array and all the radius keeps
being the same no matter what with your
computer
means there is no dependence the only
interaction you have that's a good
insight okay you're right you're right
yeah and that's why he says there's no
way there's no dependence but it's a new
one and it's sometimes you optimize it
to actually just start quickly up
Danielle wasn't only fees which is
provably little ready to do so but and
the only interaction that you can really
have and I agree on that is when in the
fold barrier but we consider the full
barrier not to be that computationally
intensive the first part of the question
can you do the you can the programmer
expressway front parallel ism these are
for matrix echo from one common creator
its parallel it's about me yes you can
it depends you you still have you still
have sequential loops of the language so
you can have a for loop your look is
your question yeah that's fine you in a
way again this happens without hopefully
without the program I'm really noticing
because the operation that he's doing on
the way front hopefully is being
expressed as an array operation and then
you iterate over array operation and the
array operations inherently are then
data parallel and actually we have we
have found this we have we have done
this experiment last year where we
actually have given this language to a
physicist and have said you know we will
try not to interact with you he is the
programming language that's how it works
ride your code and he has written a
beautiful Fortran program in sac and
what he has done is actually he has
written for loops which then iterate
over arrays and you you have seemingly
destructive updates which we can't
conceptually not do it as such however
then he applied the entire thing not to
a vector but to a large matrix so at the
end we obtained lots of data parallelism
by him just doing generalized selections
by him just selecting entire supper race
without really noticing well
computationally he was aware of that but
in a way not into to the extent that he
was thinking about doing something data
parallel on purpose and it turned out
that actually the runtime of that was
competitive with the fortran runtime so
that was a very nice reassuring
experiment that we had there
um you you use reference counting
completely to determine it you can do
destructive dates or I I would say yes
if there wasn't the word completely in
your question so I want to note in the
runtime there's an 80s right on the sea
it is array similarly using the special
code or disruptive and special girls
remember something on essentially
essentially the answer is yes however we
try to optimize that away as far as
possible and if you think about it then
essentially the alternatives in the code
are minimal because it's just a matter
of how do I get the point or where to
put the result so either I can reuse an
existing pointer or I have to allocate
some memory and give that pointer and
that's it so it's not that we have to
replicate the entire code and have it
two times there but we do have a
conditional in those cases where we
can't ethically did use that we can do
it yes but if you look at the work it's
when you specialize you all these
specialized the final cool side in the
same yeah yes because it funky app
indexing a crap yeah sure the result
won't earn any German yeah yeah and we
actually do if for example if you look
at in operation that element wise adds
up to erase then you actually have two
possibilities of reusing and we try to
figure out statically which ones are
possible or not
cache lines into account yeah we can
show it here it essentially we have the
freedom to do it in any order so let's
forget about concurrency for a second so
what we do is is actually if we have
this operation define then bear in mind
the way we have it in the compiler then
means we have an identification of the
index set associated with an operation
agreeing with the green yellow with
yellow but we try to actually linearize
that into the what we call canonical
order that is the order in which it is
in memory because we know that in this
order we are going to write it anyways
now we have actually had quite
successful experiments in analyzing the
excesses that we have right if you see
for example if you look at the
convolution then you know that you have
accesses one row to the left one column
to the left and to the right
respectively so in these cases we
actually had tiling schemes so we have a
mechanism in our compiler while you can
parameterize the compiler by the cash
characteristics of the target machine
and when we try to apply tylee however I
think we would call environment sure
unless again that's that's why I'm so
excited about this work which is in a
way already because we have the
guaranteed freedom to do that we can
actually choose this and we could have
an S smart scheduling algorithm or
placement algorithm or whatever you want
to use to do that and I think this is
lots of potential that is very difficult
to extract from it from a given C
program if possible at all so that's why
I'm so excited and I think this actually
needs to be exploited now now that the
multi-core is are really becoming
reality seemingly
so other sort of languages have had
situations where they've had
comprehensions to build a raise and in
languages with a looks particularly
those with lazy evaluation they've often
allowed you to name the result and then
recursively reference it in the
definition which gives you the ability
to do sort of dynamic programming styles
of computation so but that would
immediately kill the independence well
it yes it does well it's all right it
interferes with static scheduling right
so it's still functional in nature but
it interferes with aesthetics that your
ability to do static scheduling yeah but
you could seems like you can still fold
it into this framework except for that
caveat yeah apart from the tiny little
aspect that we are intentionally not
lazy because to have to a framework that
actually exploit laziness you need quite
a machinery which brings all kinds of
problems along which we have gracefully
avoided having said that essentially if
you look at the laziness a bit of a red
herring in the sense of its ok to
eagerly evaluate the semantics allow
that the problem is that the evaluation
of one term might require the evaluation
another and the scheduling of those
computations is hard to predict so it's
not just that that you have memory
issues that come along with it because
essentially if you if you want to do
really lazy evaluation through to the
very end then you have have to keep all
the contexts and just imagine you have a
sequence of moderate operations and you
can't just you don't just want to do
them you know then you have pointers to
the array that means f for every
operation you have to do to copy things
it turns out to be nightmare I think
you're seriously overstating the problem
well maybe maybe I am a significant
uptick in expressiveness and the kinds
of things you can describe by allowing
sort of wave fronts that process the
data and in many common cases you can
actually analyze the indexing to get
back to static schedule get back to the
Russia how do you believe a distinct
issues we were not talking about lazy
affiliation if we talk about lazy
variation I think the best argument or
the the most obvious argument I could
pose is a look at what Simon is doing
something Jones is doing and on the to
implement efficient array processing he
is putting it into interview into the IO
monad for a very good reason because
there he can actually do things
destructively because there he is not
bound to be lazy and efficiency is is
very very difficult if you are fully
lazy having said that and essentially
all these optimizations here are
introducing laziness under the hood
because what we do is if you for example
do it take on a very large array which
is defined by very difficult computation
we don't create this array we only
create those elements that we haven't
the final result so in a way this is
introducing laziness through the back
door and in fact we are looking at some
examples where would be really nice to
have some laziness but we just don't
know how to do that without losing the
performance in general
greatness thanks to speaker again